THAT IS THE ACTION HAPPENING
TONIGHT.
NOT GOING TO LIE.
WE SAW FOOTAGE OF ZION
WILLIAMSON THAT CAUGHT YOUR
ATTENTION.
ZION WARMING UP.
CHUCK, YOU HAD A VIS CAL
REACTION.
>> LOOKS LIKE ME AND SHAQ HAD A
BABY.
>> COME ON, MAN.
>> LOOKS LIKE ME AND YOU HAD A
BABY.
>> THIS DUDE.
HE EAT GOOD IN NEW ORLEANS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, ADAM.
FIRST OF ALL, I AM CONCERNED.
I AM REALLY CONCERNED.
I TELL THE STORY.
I AM BEING CRITICAL.
IT IS WHAT IT IS.
MOSES MALONE SAID I WAS FAT AND
LAZY AND I STARTED TO CRY A
LITTLE BIT.
>> REALLY?
>> I DID.
I COULDN'T KICK HIS ASS.
HE WAS MOSES MALONE.
IT WAS THE TURNING POINT IN MY
CAREER.
HE IS ALREADY HURT.
YOU SHOULDN'T GET HURT WHEN YOU
ARE YOUNG.
AND HE ALREADY HAD SURGERIES ON
HIS LEGS.
NOW HE HAS GOT A BROKEN FOOT.
HE GOING TO HAVE TO LEARN, EVEN
WHEN YOU HURT YOU ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO CONTROL YOUR EATING.
WHEN GUYS GET HURT, ADAM AND
THEY COME BACK, YOU ARE TRYING
TO GET IN SHAPE, AND IF YOU ARE
PUTTING ALL OF THE STRESS ON
YOUR KNEES AND YOUR FEET YOU ARE
GOING TO KEEP GETTING HURT.
SOMEBODY HAS TO BE A GROWN
PERSON IN THAT RELATIONSHIP AND
SAYS YO, MAN.
YOU HAVE TO GET IN SHAPE.
I KNOW HE HAS GOT A LOT OF
POWER.
EVERYBODY LIKE IF WE DON'T GET
SOMETHING GOING, HE IS GOING TO
LEAVE.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO WIN IF HE
IS ALWAYS HURT.
>> YOU DON'T PLAY BASKETBALL TO
GET IN SHAPE.
YOU GET IN SHAPE TO PLAY
BASKETBALL.
TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
YOU KNOW, HE IS A GREAT SKILLED
PLAYER.
THAT IS NOT BASKETBALL SHAPE.
THAT IS NOT TWO TO THREE WEEKS
AWAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS TONIGHT OR
SATURDAY.
THAT IS NOT A TWO WEEKS AWAY
READY BODY FOR THE NBA.
THAT IS NOT THE GUY THAT WE HAVE
SEEN FLYING THROUGH THE AIR WITH
THE GREATEST OF EASE, EITHER.
YOU KNOW, HE DOES.
>> SOMEBODY DOWN IN NEW ORLEANS
GOT TO B